here's a trans activist explaining how
being Trans in America is very similar
to being a godan during a war getting
comments that if I was in Gaza I would
be killed for being queer and first off
there are queer people in Gaza and
they're being killed for being
Palestinian secondly I don't need to
move across the ocean to experience
violence for being queer I literally had
to evacuate my place 6 months ago
because people were so violent and
sending me death threats the United
States of America for Trans people is in
stage seven and 8 Palestine is in 9 and
10 reason why this country continues to
ignore what's happening in Palestine
because our country is built on genocide
frankly I don't think you need me to
analyze any of that so instead I'd like
to show you a 10 or 15c video that I
found of that dude putting on his
makeup oh this is just you look fabulous
look at you and a little more on the
cheeks a little
more